Director:
Is this them?
Of course it's them!
Director:
The intrepid ranger who lives in
a castle in the park
Director:
with his indie journalist wife
and their two kids.
Do you guys want to see where
we're shooting this scene?
-Ahhhh!
-I thought you said you were
gonna play it cool.
Right, right.
Aww.
Better?
Weirder.
♪♪
Owen:
I got a big plan.
The more people see the park in
all of its beauty,
the more they’ll want to come!
Owen:
Who knows?
It might even get the attention
of the interim mayor.
I mean it's pretty interesting.
It's like eating a burger, but
it's in a tube.
You can't be serious.
♪Now that winter has fled the
scene we can roll up our
sleeves.♪
-You're here!
-I'm here!
Abby:
I did it.
I'm an actress living
in the Big Apple.
What part are you auditioning
for?
Customer number two.
Give us your best bite and
smile.
Here I go.
(Chomp)
I mean this in the nicest
possible way.
You look like you sat
bare-cheeked on a grumpy
porcupine.
Right, right.
♪Dig a little deeper,
sewing something better, tend
the  earth to make it last♪
Look at it.
The stupid park doesn't even
know whats coming.
How would a park know what's...
Shush, I'm plotting.
(Screaming)
-(Screaming)
-Uh. Yep. Good. Eh. Knock that
down.
And you just kicked a chicken.
♪♪
I love the idea of getting back
to basics.
♪♪
Reminding people of all the park
has to offer.
♪♪
Marvin, I know there's typos.
I'll fix them.
Ow, ow.
Uh, sorry, Owen and I are
sharing an office today.
Shampoo in my eyes, ow!
Our office is the bathroom.
♪There's always room to grow.♪
Yeah, dreams are really coming
true today.
Well hopefully not mine.
Last night I dreamt a napkin
used me to wipe it's mouth.
Oh, no it's my dream!
♪♪